is one of the workshop organized the
destination Paulo is also going to
provide its personal email address in
case you want to send any open problems
you can also use the the official one
that that I sent out earlier so I'm
hoping we can just kind of have fun in
the afternoon when we have that session
we can just kind of point out that
nothing's actually been solved and joke
about how much work we have left to do
so okay so I'm going to talk about
approximation power of deep networks and
this is an old topic it's been kind of
woven interwoven with the history of
deep networks and it's a fun topic you
can also take that to me maybe that
means the usefulness of it's in question
but it is a mathematically fun topic and
there there are new uses of it that have
come out so you know please please you
know ask questions and anything you want
to know I kind of took a random subset
of what I know so any any anything you
want to know that's not in the slides
just feel free to ask somebody in the
audience will know if it's not me okay
so let me just tell you kind of in the
most tedious way possible exactly what I
mean and then we'll get back to the fun
stuff so just to nail it down what I
mean by the approximation power just
intuitively we want to use DPRK's for a
lot of leaf networks for a lot of things
so we want to make sure that we haven't
shot ourselves in the foot by trying to
approximate something they can't you
know we want to let's say approximately
human brain we got to make sure that it
can do the same input-output mappings so
here's the formal specification of the
problem
so we've got some function we want we we
think that nature is following and we're
going to replace with a neural network
gene and our goal is that whatever the
the prediction problem was we should be
able to just stick in the neural net and
do just as well
so just just out of habit I'm going to
use the setting of statistical learning
theory that you just heard Sasha talked
about so on the Left we have the true
population risk so I've written it as
this pairwise loss function the true
population risk for some function f and
I want to do just as well with a deep
network okay for today's talk this is
the goal we want these two quantities to
be similar it's good to stress this
because a lot of people when they state
their approximation theorems they're
actually 50 miles downstream from this
and it's unclear whether what they
proved implies this but I think we can
all agree this this is a reasonable goal
a snit setting of siskel learning theory
so what you know we don't want to be
talking about loss functions we want to
be talking about F and G so to make
things simple let's just say that L is
Lipschitz in the first argument then we
can get this upper bound okay so what do
we know from this well we can say two
things one is that these risks will be
closed if these things are closed in
this l1 distance and the risk will also
be closed if these are closed everywhere
okay so a lot of people when they talk
about approximation power of deep
networks they talk about what they call
Universal approximation and what that
actually means that these are closed
everywhere which implies that this is
small which implies that this is small
but I would actually that this is the
corner we care about so I'd be happy
with proving this but note that this P
is given to you by nature you don't have
control over that P you can't just say
this is uniform or something that's
keeping it for you okay
so that's just some some terminology
people call these universal form
approximation results and if you look in
the literature people prove all sorts of
different things and and they're all
stress different problems we're also
interested in lower bounds and lower
bounds are much more dicey to pin down
what we really want to be showing
the lower bounds that I will show you
today prove an l1 lower bound that means
that this is large and l1 so what that
means there's a large there's a large
set up set with large probability mass
such that the two differ so that would
imply that on that prediction problem
they don't do similarly but you know you
can look up a lot of papers so they
actually use the lower bound they do
lower bounds in L infinity so today this
this will be our gold standard so we'll
try to make this small and we'll do it
usually by making these clothes
everywhere in this sense and the lower
bounds usually be l1 which is this
integral okay and just to pin down some
notation I'll be talking about kind of
the most standard boring version of a
deep network so it'll be this this
iterative sequence of these affine
mappings and these coordinate wise
nonlinearities I'm not going to talk
about convolutional networks I'm not
going to talk about all sorts of fancy
stuff you can ask me about the fancy
stuff if you want one there a lot of
these questions there it's easy to get
loose answers but to get tight answers
is very hard so even though you might
tell me oh a convolutional network
that's actually a way of writing down a
linear mapping with a lot of weight
sharing but actually the form of a lot
of these questions will differ if we if
we work with convolutions directly so
please ask you know don't be shy asking
questions like oh is this still true for
collars okay so so let's get on with the
fun oh and let me also point out that
I'll usually use their Lu and just for
fun I'm putting I'm putting out there
the this paper as the Rayleigh reference
thanks to a peter peter pointed out that
the this is the neo cognate Ron paper
and it used to activation functions one
of them was their value
I chose the site for the value okay so
here's where we're gonna talk about
today and again feel free to interrupt
the slides we'll go online so whatever
we don't cover doesn't matter you can
check it later
so the first thing I want to tell all of
you about are what I call elementary
Universal approximation my goal is that
everybody who comes in here for the
first 20 minutes leaves and has an
intuitive sense on why you can
approximate continuous function to the
deep networks so usually when people
talk about universal approximation they
cite some paper that you know exists and
if you open the paper you see a bunch of
Fourier analysis so that that's why I
want to do this for a section for me the
first section is the most important in
the second section I will review the
many of these classical theorems there
was basically just a whole swath of them
appeared between 89 and 93 or so and
they're really cool a lot of them have
different principles that guide them a
lot of them have different intuition you
get about what deep nervous can do and
what they can't do even if the theorem
at the end looks the same then so that
was the first two parts they prove that
we can approach the continuous functions
which by the way you might say to me you
know that's kind of a you know that's
kind of a strange goal right like you
know information theoretically you need
to work really hard to approximate
continuous function any dimensions it's
exponential in dimensions so that's kind
of a strange goal but it's a sanity
check then it will look at more refined
function families and for these we can
actually show that there's a benefit of
having more layers in the network the
first two parts will use shallow
networks the third one will not use
Shella networks the fourth one I used to
this fancy term subspace sublet space
basically just means that all the
derivatives are bounded what that means
is that you can use Taylor you can use
Taylor approximations locally and do
very well so deep networks are very good
at approximating these functions that
have well-behaved local Taylor
expansions and then to close I'll just I
basically have like eight slides each of
which could probably fill a talk and you
know we'll just see what we talk about
okay but for me actually the most
important is the first section
but when everyone just to have kind of
an intuitive sense that not only is it
clear that Dinaric can fit anything but
it's also kind of fun coming up these
little gadgets good people in the right
in the right building and in the right
city or in a we're in Berkeley it's a
weather is nice okay okay so let's start
really simple
I want to approximate this with the
neural network and I'm gonna use the
step activation ride your probably like
why am I in this room because you just
plop it down a bunch of these little
things okay you just so what I've meant
what I've drawn here is the locations
where I put them in them and the weight
I put on them so you might say what was
the point of this exercise actually
something already interesting has
happened so for those of you that are
very familiar with polynomial
approximation polynomials cannot
approximate flat regions okay you have a
function that's very flat and then has
an in complicated happen the degree of
that polynomial is going to be absurd
okay so the why am I telling you this
I'm telling you this because you might
use polynomials to explain deep networks
or use ice first or something but you've
already lost something so already we
have something interesting the
complexity of what we're describing here
does not depend on the length of these
flat regions the volume of the regions
okay to represent this I need five of
these step functions it doesn't matter
how big that flat motion is okay let's
do something more interesting let's do a
curved function still with step
functions you might say oh yeah I know
how to do this I just kind of say I want
to get epsilon close I just sort of got
little marks maybe something like this
if you add those up they kind of follow
this stair step pattern and you can say
I understand this perfectly you
subdivide the range
it's a Lipschitz function the number of
steps I need is Lipschitz constant
divided by the epsilon that's true
that's an upper bound but it's very bad
because it's paying the Lipschitz
constant that's measured over here it's
paying it here
okay I mean I'm just saying like you you
know most people they write their paper
they use this but you're you're failing
pretty badly over here and actually
there's a very clean way to there's a
elementary way well I don't know I
didn't learn this in elementary school I
than this after elementary school but
the fundamental theorem of calculus I
can just write f of X I can just write
it in terms of these step functions okay
now why is this cool you can interpret
this as being a infinite collection of
these step functions I'm exactly getting
up of X for all X so this is a measure
over values and I'll show you at the end
of the talk I can sample from this thing
I can sample from this thing so in other
words you had me a univariate function
one of my favorite ways to approximate
with a with a step function network is
that write down its its derivative I
sample from that and that gives you my
approximation and I'll tell you how to
get this I'll tell you how to get
exactly this the other talk and the cool
thing about this is it depends on the
the actual gradient so it's not paying
for this flat region okay see it's
already see this stuff is really fun you
know I had never written this down
before preparing this talk okay so to
interestings have arisen already one is
that we have a nice average case
estimate it's not a worst case bound for
the complexity of reading this with the
with the step functions another thing is
that we're using these infinite with
networks and for those of you that you
know perhaps noticed we had 237 machine
learning papers on archive yesterday it
has become very exciting for many people
to use this infinite with formalism to
study deep networks so already in the
univariate case that arises in a cool
way
okay let's keep going let's talk about
rail use
you can kind of see how this one's going
to go - every time the slope changes now
that's interesting before when the
function values changed I think it added
a step function now when the slopes
change okay so now the complexity in
terms of the rail use depends on changes
in slope which is like a second
derivative thing right so indeed if you
do a similar equality to last time this
one's skipping some duration by parts
steps you get that you can write this as
an infinite with neural network now with
the second derivative here and I can
Sabean a univariate function I take its
second derivative I sample from it I can
get my value if that sounds too vague I
give you the sampling procedure at the
end of lecture so this is cool because
it's an average case estimate and very
quickly in this talk will stop having
average case estimates very quickly in
this talk we'll have lots of worst-case
things that that's are very loose and I
should say that there's a Colt paper
from this year that studies this case in
fact this this might be in the paper and
in some sense this is actually the
optimal way of representing a univariate
function with that's the point of that
cold paper
okay that was univariate all of you
might be saying come on come on why are
univariate let's do multivariate and
just for fun let's consider a finite
point set so for finite points that we
have a trick solution the trick solution
is sample random direction the
projections are unique and I've reduced
it to univariate problem all of these
things Maps unique they have unique
projections and so I can just solve a
univariate problem now so even if your
goal was the finite point set the
representation could have really really
blown up badly if you do this so this is
actually not a good idea and our goal
was not to represent on finite point
sets so now let's go to the real case
that we care about which is we want to
approximate multivariate functions with
with an for now shallow networks
essentially okay so before and I'm doing
step functions for now so before when we
had to approximate something every time
the range of the function changed I just
stuck one of my little bumps there okay
so the goal for now is I want an
indicator on the box I want to be one
inside the box is zero outside you say
okay I'll just do what I did before I'll
just add some supporting hyperplanes so
if you add these supporting hyperplanes
and add them up then you get this
function so all I've done is I've had
taken the four supporting hyper planes
and added them up and so that gives me a
function is for inside here which is the
place where they all intersect three in
those other four agents two of those
other four regions this is not what I
wanted I wanted to be 1 here and 0
elsewhere
so let everybody think for for 20
seconds about various ways to to fix
this
and if I take too many of these 20
seconds we'll run out of time so we'll
stop so one thing you can do is you say
oh I'll use another layer I will
subtract 3.5 from everything so I
subtract 3.5 from everything
this is positive everything else is
negative play one more threshold and now
I've got the step I wanted okay cool
now I have indicator on on on this
square and for those of you that like
this sort of thing let me just state a
random sentence of analysis for you
continuous functions can be informal
approximated by indicators on boxes so I
can just add a bunch of these together
and I'm done but don't worry about that
sentence if it didn't sound exciting for
you we have a finer finer proof than
that also we failed because we've used
an extra layer so I would like to do
this with with only one hidden layer
okay so the a fine layer the value or
the step layer and then another a fine
layer and I'll just tell you right now
interestingly enough I do not know a
direct 1 layer construction for this I
thought about it for over a couple years
now I don't know how to do it the only
way I know how to do it is to hit it
with some super heavyweight overpowered
hammer about approximating continuous
functions oh and yeah this is not a
continuous function so here's a cool way
to solve this problem it was
rediscovered by one of my students
Bolton who's in the audience and it
actually turns out it's in a paper from
about 20 years ago so here's a cool
thing you can do so our strategy for the
for the cube was to add for supporting
hyperplanes well why stop at 4 right
like my GPU has you know like how much
wattage is a burden I'm not going to use
only 4 so I'm just gonna add every
supporting hyperplane I can possibly
think of and this has a really cool
property if you think about this
function then notice that points very
close to it they are kind of in the
in the they have a positive in a product
with more more of the step functions
than points farther away in fact what we
do is you draw this sort of we draw this
sort of cap in the volume of this cap is
the part you cannot see so long story
short we can actually we can actually
construct something that's sort of
morally like an indicator on a radial
ball but he's taking tons of supporting
hyperplanes okay so in my head when I
think if somebody just you know I walked
home I'm not gonna tell you when I
walked home last night
when I walked home on the street you
know I was prepared for somebody
stopping me on the street and if they
asked me you know how do you prove that
deep networks approximate continuous
functions I would just say man just you
know add add enough hyperplanes now let
me say that something we'll get to in
the later part of the story is that this
construction actually seems to require
two to the D 2 to the D nodes you use
less than 2 to the D then it's not close
at all what intuition for this is just
the number of these spherical caps we
have to approximate but I have not
written down a rigorous proof of this it
just kind of in my head so I won't I
want to promise it ok
let me just say that from here we can
approximate continuous functions by a
trick so we take a regular continuous
function and what we do is we can volve
it with this bump if I normalize this
bump to be a density then yeah this is
easier maybe if I just do it on the
board but I'll just read this one we'll
see how it goes so here's this function
I want to approximate here is it
convolve with one of these bumps and
either by change variable or properties
of convolution I can swap those two
arguments equality equality I stick the
density over there and now I am you know
push the absolute value inside this
thing is non-negative and so look at
what we were left with we're left with
this absolute value between X and
something close to X hopefully times
this probability density so if P is
highly concentrated if it's highly
concentrated at zero then then this
thing will always be small particular if
you make this like a Gaussian then we
tune in to variants to things related to
the Lipschitz constant of this okay so
what have I told you what I've told you
is that one way to approximate
continuous functions with with one layer
networks is you start by approximating a
bump with tons of supporting hyperplanes
and then you take what you get and you
can volve it with the function and with
a little little argument and some tail
inequalities on this you can prove that
your epsilon close oh and for people
that want to check this in the
literature this is called a radial basis
function okay so for me this is you know
we'll get a couple other proofs in a
couple of minutes but for me this is the
best I can do to show you at an
intuitive proof that we can approximate
continuous functions here are two
references so at some point this summer
we will hopefully put something online
but then you can look up right now this
paper by Mascara Miceli which in 92 like
I said it was in that set of years where
a lot of people worked on these things
they they also proved to result like
this
they gave a size estimate the size
estimate was roughly this okay so
exponential and dimension is this okay
so what was the point of this section so
the point of this section in the
univariate case was both to kind of get
everybody just you know back from lunch
break or sorry back from the coffee
break but also but also to point out
that even in the univariate case or
something pretty we can look at even the
univariate case there was this thing
where we can write things in terms of
integrals and oh look they're these
infinite with networks and oh look there
are these complexity measures that are
nice then I showed you that we can make
these indicator and boxes with three
layers and also these RBF convolution
constructions with two layers and they
didn't mention it clearly but if you do
the math for how big of than that the
big of the network needs to be there's
actually an extra factor D to the D here
that I don't know if it's tight or not
but it seems pretty interesting so just
a couple remarks in this section so one
is that all these constructions are very
impractical they they pay you know the
size is huge and and the Lipschitz
constant is going to scale like this
even if you're approximating very well
behaved function but a couple other
interesting things happened one is that
some of the analysis was very different
from polynomials because it was happy to
deal with flat pieces we also had this
appearance of infinite width and if you
just want another quick calculation of a
another cool way to look at infinite
width is if we have the rail you and I
want to approximate norms at the rail
you then it's just this just this quick
calculation so personally if you came to
me two years ago and said how hard is it
to compute an l2 norm with with a rail
Euler I'd say it sounds really hard but
it's really this long
and another thing that'll typify
everything else we talked about today is
that we will not get as good complexity
estimates as the ones we we just covered
so we're not going to get these nice
from the univariate case we're not going
to get these nice average Lipschitz type
bands you're going to get a lot of
worst-case pounds okay
any questions
just a little teaser depending how much
time we have just three little questions
if you want to puzzle yourself with them
we'll answer them at the end we have
time or you can just you know hunt you
down so question number one is are a
deep network if we fix the architecture
is it closed under addition so can I
take two of these add them together and
stay within the function class okay
number one question number two can i
approximate Turing machines with aren't
ends and question three everything I've
been proving was an approximation result
I was approximate any continuous
function with some network kind of get
an equality if I have a little bit of
wiggle room if I can make custom
activations that are univariate equality
one of those proofs before would give us
equality no way to do it so can I get an
equality here a little puzzles will
maybe ask them at the end okay so now I
want to tell you about the classical
universal approximation results which
like I was saying earlier are very
pretty some of them might look a little
intimidating but in all the ones I
looked at I learned something
interesting about deep networks just by
going through the proof so the first
thing I want to point out is what is the
value of multiplication so one of the
proofs will heavily rely on polynomials
and just to show you that multiplication
is interesting and gives us something
interesting so let's start with cosine
which is this outer red curve and just
raise it raise it to the power okay so
if I could just multiply cosine by
itself I can get this really nice
localized bump and I've been kind of
hinting to this whole talk that if I can
do localized bumps I can approximate
continuous functions so I can just take
powers of cosines I claimed that I could
approximate any function I wanted and
indeed here's a way to write it so if I
look if I think about the indicator of
this box as earlier so I can write it's
a product of these individual coordinate
indicators and I can also think about
the product of the cosines along every
direction so I if I look at this object
here so it's just a bunch of these
products for every dimension so it's
nice local
bump if I had if I had this then I could
approximate continuous functions in
another way and why is this interesting
well a lot of people some years back
were heavily working on on deep networks
with multiplications just baked in
probably intensively you can just you
know bacon ultra so stuff and I torch
and and so you know do you want to have
a multiplication primitive in your
network if the networks who defines so
far can do this just fine then then
maybe maybe that hints that maybe you
don't need that primitive okay so here's
a trig identity that solves this problem
so we can convert products of cosines
into just linear combinations of cosines
so there's this little trig identity I
just written two versions of it the
point of this is I can take a product
cosines and convert it into a sum of
cosines now that it's the sum of cosines
it's more like what we work with in a
one-layer network okay
so we'll use that in a second let me
just remind you about something sort of
the the maybe most classical and maybe
the result many people think about when
they think about approximation theory is
the theorem of wire Strawson HT v v that
says that polynomials can uniformly
approximate continuous functions over
compact sets and let me just say that
this is not and I would say obvious
result so I mean it's I guess acceptable
to all of us but it's not an obvious
result so for me it's very easy to
reason that polynomials can interpolate
between points you can just explicitly
write down the interpolating polynomials
set the roots to something and you can
write this down but what's not clear is
that the interpolate ink pen omie 'l
doesn't go crazy between the
interpolation points you might fix it to
do some interpolation and you might have
some sort of cat mouse game where you
keep adding more interpolation points
that keeps getting crazier between them
so the fact that it's well-behaved
between the interpolation points is
amazing and that's why these proofs are
cool the proof that many people know
it's it's in the
they're like ugh the air - book The
Ellen Spencer public method book they
they use the Bernstein proof because
it's a cool application of chebyshev's
inequality why are stresses original
proof is works with analytic functions
you take a continuous function you play
Gaussian smoothing again an analytic
function and in some sense there's some
resemblance here but it's also a cool
proof and some time ago people made a
beefed-up version of all of these which
is called the Stone Weierstrass theorem
which is that if I have any function
family that behaves like polynomials and
the key thing for us right now is that
it's closed under addition and
multiplication so it's a function class
that's like polynomials 5 f and G in the
function class F times G is also in the
function class then I get the
consequence of the Weierstrass theorem
which is that I can approximate es
functions over compact sets okay so now
we've reduced the goal of approximating
to use functions to just showing that we
satisfy the conditions of this theorem
and there are more actually but the main
one I want to highlight is we can do
products and like I was saying earlier
the fact that we can do products so
easily with deep networks is cool ok so
this is this is one of those classical
uniform approximation proofs from 1989
Hornick Stinchcomb white and the
statement goes like this it says give me
your activation function and all I need
is that whole Heather should be
constituting there too but all I need is
that it goes to 0 on the left and one on
the right I mean really swig Lee in the
middle and now I define the function
class of single nodes single network
nodes if I look at linear combinations
of these which is what we're computing
with a fine then and the activation then
a fine again this thing uniformly
approximates kikyo's function on complex
and we know from the previous slide that
we can just reduce it to that Stern
Weierstrass theorem we just have to show
that we're closed under products how do
we do that because I mean I don't know
about all of you but if you ask me if
these things are closed under product so
I can just multiply together some rail
use
sounds sounds pretty weird so here are
two ways to reduce this to the stone
Weierstrass theorem the first is the one
that's in their proof so using the trig
identity I just showed you I can work
with this class which is deep net or
shallow networks with cosine activation
so I work with cosine activations
whenever I have two of these nodes
multiplied together I can use this
identity to unravel it into a linear
combination okay so what are we shown
we've shown that we can approximate to
use functions if our activation
functions cosine that's not good enough
we want to use this arbitrary thing but
at this point it's a univariate problem
and let me explain why what I do is I
take this thing so I've got cosine of a
transpose X plus B and now all I have to
do is approximate cosine very well with
my other activation function because
then I can just feed this in as a
univariate input so I reduced it to
univariate problem
let me just say really quickly that when
when when I read this proof the the
hornik proof I was a little fuzzy on my
trig identities I felt kind of stupid
reading it and it was easier for me to
use exponentiation so you can go to the
same proof you can work with the
function class of shallow networks with
expansion activation easily closed under
products and then use the same
univariate argument okay so be shown
this is one of the classical results it
says that we can approximate Kachinas
functions and the proof method is to say
with special activations I can do
multiplication and then I can
approximate those activations with the
activation you care about so I thought
this theorem was cool for many reasons
and one was that it heavily relies upon
multiplication which doesn't seem very
comfortable when you're just working
with values okay so that's one proof
here are some comments so this theorem
seems to be for bounded activations but
you can get a rail your result out of
here by just plugging in this difference
of rail use and then you get a network
that uses these things and then you just
expand it into a network with rail use
so this is a rail your result another
thing is that if you go through the
proof and you do kind of incomplete
bookkeeping on how big all the terms are
you you do get this exponential blow-up
and dimension and it seems actually that
this Omega is quite large here's another
cool thing I'll tell you about more on
the next slide you might wonder what the
best conditions on Sigma are so there's
a very intense version of this theorem
it's actually stronger than this even
there they're discontinuities allowed to
but the version I'll tell you now is
that we're fine if and only if your
activations not a polynomial okay so for
people that not heard this result
maybe it's fun to think about it for a
little bit before I tell you how it's
proved
it's kind of funny right everybody loves
polynomials but now I'm telling you the
last thing you should do with your deep
network is use a polynomial activation
or if this is an idealized result right
I have like infinitely I have any budget
I wanted i've known as i'm not saying
you know and practice you know maybe
like X to the fourth is the best
activation history I don't know okay
okay so here are some other theorems let
me just do a time check to make sure I
don't finish on like slide five oh you
mean you want a lower bound for how many
nodes we need to approximate
multiplication this is actually super
complicated I will give you two answers
right now and we'll come back to it
later people are obviously obsessed with
this because of how important
multiplication is the first thing I can
tell you is that those earlier let
bounds I gave you for it for um oh let
me also tell everybody that here's just
a little whoa there's a little trick
that whenever I talk about
multiplication I'm going to talk about
squaring by something called the
polarization identity and there are many
ways to write this but one way is okay
so I don't need them so because of this
if I can do squaring I can do
multiplication
it actually for this one it works out
that all the formal proofs about this
okay so the answer the question
everybody remembers earlier I had that
average Lipschitz construction and
gloriously not he has walked in as I was
saying there is that that theorem that
says that these um these infinite with
constructions are are the minimum norm
solutions so you can use that to get
probably to get some sort of lower bound
for this shallow construction okay so
that's shallow constructions later I'm
going to tell you about deep
constructions for multiplication so deep
constructions for multiplication is
known that we could get additive epsilon
with a network whose size is log 1 over
epsilon depth and width you might say
great the problem is that the Lipschitz
constant of this network is actually 1 R
epsilon so let's be clear here
I'm proximity x squared which has which
is constant of 2 on 0 1 y is my
Lipschitz constant it going crazy so
this is unfortunate ok but I know that
was a very long answer for a for short
question there is evidence but it's this
is very incomplete they go through a
bunch of these classical ones let me
just do another time check okay so I'll
just tell you these in maybe two
sentences the one that most people talk
about is this proof by George C Banco
and it works as follows it uses a high
powered version of orthogonality called
the Hahn Banach theorem and it reduces
the problem to saying that if I have
some fancy signed measure then this
integrals this inner product here if you
will is 0 if and only if the measure is
0 that's basically saying that if I have
some measure and it if it has any bumps
then I can always pick them out with
these and here's the Fourier analysis to
prove that ok then there's this proof I
was telling you about that says that if
and only a few activations opponent not
a polynomial you can approximate
continuous functions so let's do the
negative Direction first if my
activation is a polynomial
linear calm
of polynomial do not increase the degree
so if my activation has degree D or R
sorry if my activation has degree r I
can't even approximate things that are
degree R plus one okay so that's why if
your activation function is a fixed
degree polynomial you're in trouble the
other direction is absolutely insane the
the other direction what it says is that
suppose you're not a polynomial it does
a little bit of math and proves that you
have been a filly many derivatives it
does not improve smoothness and form
infinitely many derivatives it points
out that you can do a bunch of clever
math to basically get any monomial you
want and I'll just tell you one little
trick from the proof
notice that okay here's my AK - I'm
gonna work univariate right now here's
that activation okay here's my
activation you're just you're just some
univariate network right I'm gonna
subtract off this that's a network and
I'm gonna scale everything by 1 over
towel does this look like anything to me
but what do I take some limits
so you can if you have a function in
your neural net class you can write its
derivative in a class using that you can
fancily get polynomials okay it doesn't
sound so I'm just trying to show you how
cool this proof is see this is this is
why I like a lot of these proofs you
read them and you find all this crazy
stuff okay then the Behrend proof is
extremely interesting one way to look at
the baron proof is like this the baron
proof that everyone talks about it but
for many reasons many people talk about
the sampling procedure the baron proof
is effectively using a complex it's
using a complex exponential activation
function and if used this complex
exponential activation function I can
write any function I want as an infinite
with Network where the measure on my
activation is given by the body by the
Fourier transform by inverse Fourier
transform there isn't this cool it's so
cool it's saying I could have my f of X
and I can write it like this and to get
his bounds he takes the real part of
this and then samples from this integral
so I knew about this paper for like 10
years I was scared of the Fourier
analysis and all I knew about it was
this Mori sampling thing which is
amazing and ten years later I like check
some of the Fourier analysis and it's
it's amazing okay that's cool another
cool thing about this other theorem is
that you get an estimate that's not just
one over L over epsilon of the deep so
you actually get an estimate for how
many nodes you need that can be a lot
better I should also say that that there
is another paper by photo Hoshi that I
have only skimmed it's from the same era
it is not cited often I think just due
to coincidences and it looks pretty
intense I was reading it last night and
I just saw a bunch of Fourier theorems I
didn't know so okay so I got kind of too
excited but you can see that on one hand
these are kind of lame theorems you
might say oh who cares Bucky's functions
all the estimates are exponential but
for every one of them you learn
something cool about how to use networks
and how to combine them and things like
that that's why I like these
okay it's just a few quick comments that
we haven't done anything with depth and
we haven't even done anything with
neural networks a lot of these proofs we
could just change some words and the
same proof shows that boosting and RBF
SVM so I mentioned it to everybody this
use of the exponential activation let me
tell you how I thought of this I was
reading in Ingo Stein Ward's books the
proof that SVM's therapy of activation
can fake to use functions and I was
reading and I thought wait a minute this
is a neural net theorem okay you have
any questions
twelve-thirty right any questions I get
too excited talking about this stuff I'm
able to talk about this stuff for years
aren't these cool like okay now I want
to talk about okay so so far I have
given you what I claimed originally was
an intuitive explanation that we can
approach meteos functions but ended up I
guess not being that intuitive the
second part was I reviewed a bunch of
these classical theorems so far
everything has been shallow shallow
representation the only hint I had of a
non shallow representation was when I
used three layers to approximate the Box
function and saved the D to the D factor
maybe okay
so now I will talk about a variety of
results that use depth to show that
there are nice things you can
approximate a little bit of depth a
little bit of extra depth and they have
lower bounds with them okay
so the first thing I want to tell you is
that actually let me just do another
time okay so I will just tell you this
slide in an impressionistic way so what
I want all I'm telling you here is that
reality elections are easy to
approximate with two layers one layer
computes a squared norm which you can
just do coordinate wise and the other
layer just approximates the function the
only reason I wrote up the calculation
was because this hideous triangle
inequality is actually what kills lots
of deep network papers so the paper that
Dylan Foster Peter Berlin and I wrote
that has this spectral normalized bound
it has this exponential Lipschitz
constant baked-in and it's because of a
step like this okay so that's why I
wrote that step you I will you slide to
be posted you can you can check them
later the punchline is that two layers
radial functions or to rally layers
radial functions easy okay if we only
have one value layer it's soup or not
easy so as I was hitting before there
exists okay let's just go through this
slowly
this is by Ronan Alden and ohad Shamir
so this result says that if there exists
a radial function f and it's a very
complicated randomly constructed radial
function so this is not an easy result
to prove or just imagine even so there
exists a radial function f which if we
have two rel you layers we can do just
finding it really close with polynomial
complexity so there exists this function
and a probability measure so I've kind
of missed a little on my original goal I
I'm constructing a probability measure
that'll make the lower bound a little
better okay so thanks to probably
measures so that anything with only one
rel you layer and exponential size has
constant lower bound so it's a constant
away this does not depend on dimension
or anything else this is really just
some some constant and I should say that
it's not this proof is is terrifically
difficult and it's been for years and it
hasn't it hasn't been redone actually it
hasn't so just making this like the
uniform measure or something it hasn't
been done you think there's another
result I think I know the other results
will just mention the same the proof is
super intense the proof says there's an
l2 norm I can just Fourier transfer
everything inside of it and everything
stays the same and then if I look at the
Fourier transforms the two layer thing I
or the the one layer thing I know
exactly what that really transform is it
look for this weight transfer is this
all these little tubes and the other guy
is he's huge the tubes can't cover the
cover it I'm not gonna say more about it
the proof is is a super-intense i was
reviewing it again last night and
finding more steps that had forgotten
about so it's a it's a kind of a tour de
force proof if you want just a bunch of
really intense Fourier transforms if you
like if you like this guy named Bessel
then you should check this proof okay so
here is a very nice related result not
not directly implying it but very nice
so now we have two inputs we'll just say
they're both D dimensional their uniform
dispute distributed on the sphere okay
and now what I'm looking at is the sine
function
ah story of their product and because of
this products and norms are related I
can just make this all norms ok so this
function H the sine of this product I
can approximate our let me let me say
this way so if I have a single layer and
my width is D to the D then I can't get
within a constant and this is really the
uniform measure now this is great the
only thing that's weakened since last
time is I have a bound on the weight
magnitudes the weight magnitudes have to
be at most to 2d which I don't know
about you but in my PI torch code I'm
not getting up to 2 to the D on my rally
weights and we can approximate this
really easily with two layers okay so
the main thing to think about the
difference between these two is that
this one sweats really hard and does not
have the bound on the on the weights and
this one has the bound on the weights
proofs are completely different the
proof of this one uses a system it
Danielli and it has this he's very good
with I remember I wrote to Matthew found
this proof I was like how did you do
this he's like yeah I'm just good at her
Thugga nope oh no meals so so use
orthogonal polynomials on the sphere
that's called spherical harmonics and
you basically just use these lemmas that
Emmet I'm at new and you reduce it to
univariate problem you're just comparing
two functions on the line and now it
becomes a region counting argument that
all I'll show you in a second so I I
really like this proof a lot is very
clean and the idea behind the proof is
different this is not merely a technical
thing that this bound it's it's actually
internally a different proof or okay
maybe we can ask all three of them if
it's I think it's a very different proof
though okay so do another time check do
another calibration so let me give you
my intuition on why this problem is hard
this intuition is not I think explicitly
what makes the proofs work and also this
intuition as far as I know has not been
converted into a proof by anybody so you
could just take this s you know my
little bull's eye
if you will but for me this is my
intuition on how these how these how
these what's going on here let's say I
want to approximate some radial function
and the radial function the way I'm
writing it is just this is this contour
plus it's some value in this shell some
value on this shell of some other value
some other value on these different
shells if I could approximate these
individual shells I could just add them
together and approximate the function
okay now here's the problem if you try
to approximate this thing with with one
of our little networks here's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna make the width of
this one over D I make the width of this
one over D that shell that's constant
volume and the problem now is this thing
is so small that you if you if you push
your hyperplane very close to this inner
ring and you're gonna need exponentially
many of these and if you push it any
farther you're gonna catch a lot of the
0 and you're getting the wrong answer so
my intuition on what's going on in these
proofs again this intuition has not been
converted into a proof my intuition is
that you basically end up with these
little thin shells and you just need
there's basically exponentially many of
these little caps you have to cover
related to the fact that they're
exponentially many nearly orthogonal
directions and then high dimensional
Gaussian so let me tell you one more
result so what we've discussed so far is
that if we have one rail you layer we
have trouble with radial or Rayleigh
radial like functions and with two
regulators we can do really well the
natural question is what can do with
different numbers of layers so for this
let's go back to the drawing board so if
we have a shallow representation it's an
addition of functions a single layer or
whatever what are we bad at so we're bad
at many things but one of the things
were bad at is imagine by a very bump a
very bumpy function
so at least in my head whenever I have a
very bumpy function if I'm working with
one of the usual kinds of bases we have
I have to kind of use them their base
this element for every one of these
that's just what I have baked into my
head
another support vector for each one or
something so let's try to build a
function which gets bumpy as fast as
possible and try to approximate the with
a shallow thing and see what happens so
here's a little observation so this
thing called the tent map from dynamical
systems I've I guess you can kind of
tell it's blue and a red so I've colored
one half blue and one half red if I take
some function and I apply it to the
output this is what happens so this this
here is just going from zero to one and
this here just going to 0 to 1 backwards
so f of triangle of X or F of 10 map of
X is just two copies of F the second one
being reversed ok so again the way the
way I do this in my head is is I get one
copy of the domain in this composition I
get one copy of the domain a second copy
of the domain bathroom and so if you do
the natural thing that people do when
they like to break things which is
composed with itself then we get two
peaks and you keep doing it the number
of peaks grows exponentially you keep
duplicating and shrinking this function
every single time ok so again the
punchline is K compositions of this
thing give you 2 to the K bumps so the
idea is that you hand me any basis you
want then what I'm you're just going to
do is with very little effort construct
a super bumpy function that you're your
base is going to have to choke so if you
tell me I believe in Fourier transforms
you know with sinusoids up to you know
1024 oscillations yeah no problem I'll
just you know state 20 in the exponent
here
okay so so I'm just doing a little time
calibration so here's what we can prove
with this something I did a couple years
ago it was essentially concurrent
concurrent with the with the result and
and yeah it was really funny we ran into
each other we ran into each other at
because based on the year I'm not sure
what they called the conference anymore
but we ran into each other it was like
hey so what did you prove and it was
like oh okay okay hey you proof shall I
prove deep okay but but okay so you give
me an integer the way this theorem works
is like this you give me an integer you
say I believe in depth K you know I've
used pipe touch on my life depth 100 is
the best thing ever I construct a
network with K squared layers and K
squared nodes
I used that triangle mapping the tenth
map and you can't approximate it so in
other words again the game goes like
this you tell me you believe in K lairs
I say bad news if your if your size is
less than exponential then you can't
approximately I think that has K squared
layers okay so just a few comments on
this proof so here's how the proof goes
so step one is this intuitive claim that
if I have a highly oscillatory function
it cannot be approximated by a few
oscillation function okay so that's the
that's the intuitive claim that's part
of the proof it's the three close to the
proof that's one of them another
component of the proof is to say there
exists such an oscillatory function we
already know that we just constructed it
and
and another part of the theorem is to
say that with the shallow Network we
can't hope to have a function with many
offs with few oscillations and there are
many reproofs of this I proved it in the
univariate case because it's just some
simple accounting argument I think one
of my favorite versions of the proof is
essentially in here
this paper proves the VC dimension of
polynomials in 1968 in the West and it
cites yeah ok let's not go into it but
and then I was creepily stalking
vladimir arnold on youtube by using his
Cyrillic name and I skimmed two random
point a video and I saw him doing this
counting argument on a chalkboard so
some some reference to to vladimir
arnold there's also this paper by
montipora pescado Cho and ben geo which
was studying all the different arranging
yet with these Rayleigh networks that
also had this counting argument and then
me and my student Bouldin who I
mentioned briefly we also included a
version of it is essentially a
vc-dimension arguing so because of that
I will not prove this I will point out
this so our goal is to say that a
function with few oscillations cannot
approximate a function with many
oscillations
every time I sat down to prove it my
proof was complicated so maybe it's fun
to just think for a second it's an
intuitive claim but but so here's here's
how I proved it I said okay well first
problem is that if I have my high
oscillatory F in my low oscillatory G
this is actually not enough so I've
drawn the l1 norm here between them if F
has many oscillations but they're
scrunched up I can't prove this high gap
okay so I need F to have very kind of
balanced oscillations so that's why this
word regular was appearing earlier that
I'd mentioned okay so we have a function
with these regularly spaced with these
regularly spaced oscillations and I want
to show that something with fewer
oscillations can approximate I just say
that this relates the fact that my goal
I was stating my goal as being the l1
norm lower bound but many people are
happy with L infinity lower bounds in
which case this argument have been fine
okay so here's one way to do the
argument what you do is you all set you
isolate one oscillation of G and with
very few exceptions you use an average
agreement and the proof most of the of
these large oscillations in G will hit
many many small oscillations in F and
there are so many of these oscillations
in F but all I have to do is pay
attention to the ones on the other side
of this line I've drawn so again the way
the proof works is isolate single
isolations of the few oscillation
function and in those places I just look
at across the line one half of the
oscillation the other direction by the
highly oscillatory function so this
proof it gets I think I wrote the number
1 over 32 that should be it should be
about 1/2 this only gets 1 over 32 due
to various forms of laziness one of them
being that it doesn't bother with with
these regions okay so here's the punch
lines from this part of the talk so the
punch lines are that there are radial
functions that seem very simple and two
layered networks are just two hidden
layer to regular networks are fine with
them we
exponentially complex if you only have
one regular those are the results by
eldan schmear and by Matt Danielli sorry
Brunel done oh hush Mir hi Daniela and
then we have this result of for any
depth K comparing it to K squared so
here's some remarks so this function is
2 to the K Lipschitz and maybe I'll have
time to mention it later but I've been
highlighting a lot of these
constructions where their lips in some
where they're not I'm slowly believing
less and less in high Lipschitz
functions so because don't expect to get
them out of pi towards basically and a
week maybe an open promised session
later we can discuss many variants of
all these questions we can talk about
you know the ideal question be if you
give me a K lair network I give you an
algorithm when determines whether we
should add another layer or not right
this is the question everybody wants to
know I ran PI torch and ResNet 100
should I do present 101 I wish I could
and another thing I should say is that
all of these constructions were
constructions they weren't claims that
you run into these things with gradient
descent
they weren't claims that you know see
far with you know SGD with whatever SVR
G is running into them or something ok
any questions so far
each have a difference of only one of
your question is run itself is the
different non-linearity Oh info nothing
the death in the way yeah
interestingly and many of the proofs it
actually doesn't matter it if you use a
different no linearity for every single
one so I just happen to read that
sentence last night in eldan Shamir's
proof and and in all of my proofs it
also doesn't matter and and I'm this
professor I remember but in a lot of
them it doesn't matter
oh yeah sure it's basically just the
fact that they're all just easily
convertible with each other like you
give me you give me a that's why I'm
talking about rally I should have
mention this this one time I really used
to roast this talk you give me whatever
whatever activation you care about I'll
just use a bunch of really approximated
no actually you can do this with vanilla
where you pay like a one over epsilon
type thing are you're not still bad but
it's not a fully satisfying answer I
mean the reason I'm doubling down on the
Raelians because really has all these
magical properties like positive
originating but I guess the summarize
the question is for just like stating
these existence type here because of
these types of things that doesn't
really matter but maybe for some refined
questions it matters
yeah so information that using less loss
for a functional puss and hiding us on
reading isn't that people have been
doing with beds we didn't what floor
your trust ones trying to do I mean is a
low-frequency to possibly higher
frequency or there's a fundamental
limits there right sure yeah there's
just an already there yeah I mean what
what I mean what I guess I'm saying here
is that actually interestingly India
some there's some old monograph by viola
Coonan and Benjy aware they they
actually this was before any of these
proofs happen to where they state that
and a good a good evidence of the power
of depth is approximating Fourier
transform is being about the butterfly
network that we use to compute Fourier
transforms and also yeah the way I would
say it is that if you give me a fixed
basis of some size it has some maximum
frequency and I can quickly beat that
frequency with with the deep network but
I'm also cheating right I'm getting to
pick my architecture yeah that's a good
question
okay let me do it this way so let me
tell you let me try to be clean for the
first time I'm sorry 65 so let me tell
you somewhat cleanly what this result is
all about so I've told you that I
answered this questionnaire that we can
do multiplication and I want to tell you
the punchline for this construction you
you can look at it in the slides in
detail or in the paper outside this is
this is not mine
so x squared is one of these functions
that we can get epsilon close with log 1
over epsilon depth log where epsilon
width and the proof of this is like a
like a trick proof if you form the
piecewise outline interpolation
subtracting from each other you get
these tech maps you add the 10 maps
together then then you get the result so
here's that here's the bound you you can
take these triangles I told you about
add a bunch of them together and you get
x squared and it's epsilon close with
with complexity logo rep salon and this
gives us multiplication okay so we have
multiplication we have squaring we've
got polynomials okay so anything you can
write with the polynomial we can
approximate well but I want to tell you
about in this section of the talk is
going one step beyond just polynomials
which is things with locally with
locally good Taylor expansions so you
know we take the Taylor expansion it
drifts after well so I can't just
replace a function without I'm not just
time I replace two functions the
polynomial
I'm placing it locally with a polynomial
so here's the theorem and let's give you
some some highlights from it so if you
gave me a DVD demand if you give me a
d-dimensional function and I say it has
smoothness order are people that that
know the lingo I actually don't
I just basically picked it up it's this
is called the Sobel of all there are
many different sublet balls with many
different norms this version of the
Sobel live ball is just saying that all
the derivatives up to our part all the
partials up to degree are are bounded by
one okay you need this function with all
these smoothness condition
then there exists a network with
essentially log on or epsilon it's so
hard to read that's e I was trying to be
tricky
it's love on a rep salon blog owner
epsilon over here the depth is log on up
long that's necessary in this
construction and but we're not caring
about the magnitude of the weight so
that's log 1 epsilon is necessary and
the width scale is like 1 over epsilon
but it gets very good with the
smoothness order this was proved by your
outski in 2016 and a bunch of other
people around the same time and then
after that I'll mention the references
in just a second
this is the proof that I've gone through
in detail over there okay so so this
proof is pretty cool what it does is
that takes the function computes all
these Taylor expansions everywhere so
you get these little local polynomials
and then it multiplies them by bumps
okay so I've got I've got my function I
got my function f I want to approximate
it here by polynomial and I multiply it
by a bump like this i compute the
polynomial and then I multiply it by
this bump why is that interesting
polynomials themselves can't approximate
bumps with low degree so this
construction is kind of non polynomial
even though it's using polynomials okay
so that's how the proof works and just a
few quick comments the Lipschitz
constant up according to me is kind of
bad like I said later I'll mention why
that big Lipschitz constant scare me
I'll also say that to some extent this
result is actually a basis expansion you
the only part of the construction that
depends on F are the these coefficients
on these bump times polynomials so it's
still not using depth as much as it
could in some sense so there is another
related resultant paper here's some
other results I should mention so around
the same time Safran Shamir also proved
this they did not use the x squared
construction I just told you about
they used a related one that did bit bit
digit extraction but it it actually has
a similar Lipschitz confidence so that
applies there and I checked all these
other proofs out of paranoia they all
have the same Lipschitz constant
internal
if you like if you like if you're
curious about the other so blow of norms
and
but you can check these other papers
how its discipline the constancy they
are and how they fell oh yeah I'm pretty
nervous about those okay nervous about
those it was pretty careful in that
paper yeah sorry no no it's not my head
it's like rude for me to say that I'm
nervous I'm nervous about the emotions I
should check them let me hand it to you
so they're completely constructive and
in fact like I said you only need for a
new function f you only need to compute
these multiplication coefficients and
the base is already lying around yeah
it's a complete constructive proof this
paper it writes the pre-crisis proof out
very nicely and it talks about
partitions of unity and has little
pictures and lower bounds - and yeah
this is a great paper oh sorry there was
a one-word answer that question
constructed okay so I want to stay there
so let me okay
I should let me just take five minutes
to grab bag some things and then let me
just take two minutes to grab back
things we have enough time for questions
right
let me just answer these questions the
answer is no there's an upper bound on
how many pieces we can have if I perturb
these add them to themselves a bunch of
times I'm going to exceed the upper
bound on how many pieces this
architecture can have this actually
Falls not closed under addition but you
know I kind of tricked you maybe I said
fixed architecture maybe the word fixed
I'd anything define right Arne in cement
Turing machines yes they can you use F
to model the state transition table and
you encode the tape in a single real
number but it's not easy you for a fact
I'll tell you later just really I don't
know this people that have been around
me for more than five minutes I keep
repeating this the step function is not
a computable function so yeah this this
function X maps to 1 if X is greater
than equal to 0 0 if X less not
computable after reading from 98 bits so
to do digit extraction on this state is
non-trivial
this is cool result but this it's true
that you can do this if the coma bar for
an old theorem this 156 and the proof is
really intimidating it's just a bunch of
limits and it constructs these
fractional bases the slides have this
very offensively short sketch of the
proof but the activations have like high
fractal dimension and stuff so it's not
you're not gonna plug this you will not
plug in a PI torch yeah for the first
question maybe you addressed this
already I missing and I apologize but if
you were to consider infinite networks
would say bounded nor and does that
answer change ok infinite with your fine
bounded norm the answer or something
about a norm because maybe you can
to create a set of weights so I think
this is a question so I'm not just like
you know the answer I think this is a
question that will dance will depend a
lot on the exact the exact way we set it
up so there you know if I like add and
normalize then I think with them I think
we're maybe fine but if I can add and
not normalize then but I can get all
sorts of crazy stuff and yeah I I think
based on the we have all summer right we
can talk about it but it basically the
explicit version of it the answer might
change if you want to extract L bits you
need l lens but you fix the depth yeah
yeah yeah
oh maybe I should say Egypt needs to
have that sort of arbitrary depth yeah
this thing is yeah and it takes many
steps to do to this I'm going yeah maybe
I should have pointed out that there's
actually another whole set of the talk
but let me just pick one thing from here
that's interesting the sampling thing I
did not explain that the sampling works
this is super cool the original
reference thanks to my friend max
emergence key is Quran Griffiths there
was a recent paper by bison Gilbert
Tiwari and then I use a version this is
relate to if you just write down
Rademacher complexity bound and you just
you just kind of confuse yourself that
you switch XNA you convert the
Rademacher generalization bound into a
uniform norm bound
use so what does this tell us it tells
the probability 1 minus 1 over epsilon
over e I only need constant probability
I'm just saying there exists one of
these things I can use generalization
bounds to guarantee that sampling from
these infinite with networks that gives
us something cool get any slides be
posted just gonna say really quickly
that I keep talking about the Lipschitz
constant to some extent Lipschitz
constant hi means you have adverse trail
examples but it's not so simple if you
have examples for a part you kind of
want to be flat there so there's there
are some aspects of adversarial examples
and I was fearless ability that changed
a lot of the nature of these
representation questions and I think
it'd be really exciting if people
started working on on things like
representation questions related to
adversarial stability so that was so
vague let me just see if there was
something else I skipped they wanted to
include another thing that's another
representation thing that's pretty
interesting is for generative networks
very simple things like you have a
uniform distribution you split it up
into two you know two uniform
distributions over disjoint sets that
that's discontinuous so a lot of these
kind of mappings people are very
comfortable with in in ganz and VA EES
are actually kind of very very badly
behaved and maybe it has something to do
with some aspects of the training that
are difficult let me also say that I was
very shocked reading these papers is
just came outta left field for me these
papers that give some convergence
results for for gay descent on deep
networks they have the representation
results inside of them and one of them
says they used give me this wide network
you take a tiny perturbation get any
function you want so there are all sorts
of new representation questions that can
be can be best to get advice based on
this okay I think I should stop for
questions
[Applause]
Russians
boots on its back for lunch